jodie sweetin se retrouvent ce soir au
matin nous apprennent qu'ils soient
indépendants ont regardé la vidéo mais
c'est con ce que je vais dire mais
j'arrête jamais bordel alors là je viens
de revenir de la faille lui il peut vous
dire que c'est quand même tu es chose de
vraiment incroyable alors c'est très
simple j'aille là-bas donc je veux ma
cherché à assurer des acides billets
lorsque ses parents se désole et on les
cherche et tourne et que la question
devait être question mais où sont ils au
dessus ou chaude il tenait à tout le
match les notes et au final
risma retenue et puis un moment on n'a
pas cité son bien avec eux et
franchement c'était à croire que c'est
moi j'avais envie de faire ça et
franchement je peux me dire que la paris
games week
c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
bien en plus ya plein de gens qui vont
connu pendant avoir une centaine de
personnes pour tranquillement reconnu
kim ont refait leur j'ai un truc
de laquelle dans la bouche donc je
disais qu'ils m'ont connu et tout est
franchement c'était vraiment sympa ça
avec plaisir avec qui on rend des faits
un autographe calment moi j'étais
choquée et coiffe un jeu si l'on
considère pas du tout comme un mec super
connu que je vais jusqu'à 10
vidéo et depuis ça plaît attendant voilà
enfin je veux dire je ne sais pas la
piste pop up est et squeeze ici hockey
le trio service du dégage merci non mais
pas du tout moi j'étais comme tout le
monde me balader comme des gens me
connaissent et ça me faisait plaisir je
me disais à quelqu'un de fils qui
regarde les vidéos c'est ce qui est
franchement sa part et et puis voilà
avant c'était super génial bref on a
filmé près de 230 vidéo à la paris games
week
donc je peux vous dire que avant de
faire lever tôt paris games week on va
mettre pas mal de temps à apprendre et
je sais le faire autrement mais je pense
qu'ils à prendre toutes les vacances au
moins puisque je vais faire d'autres
choses du coach est sûre en tout cas
même s'il est ou non je pense que ça
vient prendre toutes les vacances mais
croyez-moi ça en voilà le coup mais
franchement sandra lou je voulais aussi
ça un petit bisou à monsieur vélo à hugo
et à boire d'ailleurs c'est la nécessité
parce que c'est l'espagne qui auraient
du mal et je confirme en tout genre les
mecs vous étiez comme ça c'est pas comme
ça comme ça et donc je voulais aussi
dire que je revais à l'appareil de
tweets lundi donc j'y mets pas du mans
je suis désolé pour tous ceux qui vont
jugement j'ai peur qu'ils n'ont pas
aujourd'hui ou qui est ou pas les imams
et voilà c'est comme ça je les utilise à
sion enfin bref c'est compliqué en ce
moment et puis c'est con
tél
vous allez voir c'est corey vous y aura
quelque chose
donc en gros jb lundi donc pour ceux qui
iront lundi vous mais la vaisselle perdu
ses lunettes et se souciait juste là
comme d'habitude
hop un peu crade et que je marque
desurmont parfois sembler anodins
deviennent métiers d'accor étant donnée
la étant donné le musée bas et la
étant donnée la luminosité qui fait dans
la chambre viergele aussi donc je vous
dis à lundi pour tous ceux qui vont à la
fin il joue lundi en attendant pour ceux
qui demain le même si je suis pas là ce
n'est pas la fin du mythe du temps des
uns qui sépare y aura des gens je crois
la péniche 9-3 face en europe
j'ai des gens qui ne jouent pas dans le
dur on s'en fout l'important c'est déjà
lui tout le matin si vous voulez tester
de nouvelles 3 parce qu'il faut savoir
qu'il est environ quatre heures de queue
vois tu arrives à 13 heures
même le matin offert enfin de jouer à
être partie de modern warfare 3 bref
j'espère que vous serez nombreux encore
à venir me voir lundi ce sera encore une
fois je vous accueille avec joie et bras
ouverts le et puis je vous dis à lundi à
tous et à toutes
et en attendant le fin le best of de la
paris games week des ja et tie-2 donc
jour un jour 2 eh ben je vous mets tout
de suite un petit extrait de latence
qu'on a fait sur le truc des black eyed
peas avec louise recevoir c'est quand
même quelque chose de vraiment marrant
je danse comme un vieux jeu c'est à vous
les studios et puis très vite de cette
can en tout cas vous serez vraiment
comme un diable on connaît tous à venir
me voir n'hésitez pas york
aucun souci on peut même un peu dommage
y'a vraiment odeurs saucier et je vous
laisse donc sur cette vidéo de moi et
qu'il en avait assez de reese est assis
demi vie est mon ami hugo de la paris
games week
vous dites c'est le je veux dire
tout le monde ou pas cholette souvent
d'un docu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]